I knew nothing I didn't have a social
media presence I didn't have a Facebook
page didn't have YouTube didn't have
anything and I just jumped in then I
just had to adopt to who I am right I'm
not technical I'm not going to edit
videos how much did you generate an ad
Revenue over 80 000 just from AdSense
what are maybe some of the habits or the
traits that you think are essential to
create what you have done and that is a
a YouTube channel should I start a
YouTube show or a video podcast or
something like that what advice would
you have what if I told you that it's
possible to build a highly successful
YouTube channel earning eighty thousand
dollars a year just from ad Revenue lots
more from multiple income streams
growing tens of thousands of subscribers
and not editing any of your videos well
in today's episode of the think media
podcast I'm excited to talk with Michael
Zuber from one rental at a time he's a
real estate investor best-selling author
background as an economist that's his
education and is going to be dropping a
lot of wisdom and a lot of areas in this
episode but as a YouTube Creator he has
really built one of the most unique
models that I've ever seen on YouTube
that I know that you'll be able to learn
from for your own content especially if
you're looking for different ways of
creating content easily quickly and
simply and so uh Michael welcome to the
podcast thank you very much appreciate
the opportunity and so for people just
meeting you who are you in a nutshell as
far as kind of you know your career and
what you're doing today I would say I'm
a former Tech worker right who grew up
in the Silicon Valley I was investing in
the stock market pre-internet bubble
right did quite well turned seven Grand
into almost 200 only to lose 80 percent
of it which is quite painful some folks
today may you know feel similarly with
crypto or other things from that I went
on to start a buying real estate as the
way to have a better financial future
did that for 20 years ultimately left
the corporate job at 45 and have been
retired for over five years so that's
that's who I am and so then you launched
a YouTube channel and really a brand
when did one rental at a Time start one
rental at a time started about two weeks
after I retired because I was getting
depressed as a as somebody who was type
a go-getter had a quota for 20 years I
could only operate moving forward right
I didn't do still well yeah uh so I was
actually at my kitchen table regretting
the idea of accepting a job offer
because I'm very good at what I do and
people were headhunting me and offering
significant packages and I just sat
there at 45 at my kitchen table going
I may have to take a job on Monday not
because I needed it
but because my ego wouldn't let me and I
just remember sitting there going you're
an idiot
you know you should take this as an
opportunity to try to share your story
that's where one rental at a time just
the name popped in my head because
that's what we did for 20 years yeah and
you know I said I'm gonna give this a
shot
I'm going to give this a shot for 30 to
60 days and see what happens and I knew
nothing I didn't have a social media
presence outside of LinkedIn right which
was what you used for business I didn't
have a Facebook page I didn't have you
didn't have YouTube didn't have anything
and I just jumped in and I found think
media and things like that that said
that made me feel comfortable because I
could understand it then I just had to
adopt to who I am right I'm not
technical I'm not going to edit videos
so that went out the window right I um I
didn't have space I wasn't gonna I was
willing to spend a little bit of money
but I wasn't gonna you know go buy
thousands of dollars of equipment so my
phone was was my camera for a long time
I recorded out of my kids bedroom for a
long time and yeah so
it was a lot of fun but that's that's
that's my story with YouTube and so it
started what year I believe 18. okay so
you started one rental at a time and
that was your model meaning one rental
at a time you invested money you set
aside from your salary correct into one
rental at a time exactly and then and
then once things started to compound you
could cash out refi or re refinance and
all that stuff so you kind of started
with that Vision one of the things
you're known for today one of my
favorite shows on YouTube is daily
financial news has that been going the
entire time uh I wasn't called that in
the beginning but yeah I would say it's
always been about five days a week in
the beginning when I didn't really have
a I didn't really figure out YouTube my
version of it for the first year I was
trying lots of different things right if
you went to my channel looked at my
playlist I tried lots of different
things to feel what what it felt like to
me uh the daily financial news really
was probably one of the first thing that
hit because I didn't change anything
other than taking notes for 20 years I
wake up ungodly early without an alarm
clock and I read for 60 to 90 minutes so
I've been doing that for 20 years I
haven't changed a thing other than I
take notes and I maybe cite sources just
so people can go find the Articles so
that that that was the first thing that
really felt good to me was the daily
financial news there's a lot of nuggets
in there I think one you you took that's
such a picture of turning your passion
into profit taking what you already do
what you're already curious about what
already fascinates you what's already
that you're not like it's not a tactic
like oh this would do well on YouTube
you've been living consuming data that
someone like me does not consume and
does and wants synthesized and so you
then turn that into a show what you
already read what you already research
and then you also mentioned a powerful
nugget in there that it took you about a
year to figure things out so for I know
a lot of people looking thinking about
starting like they just want this thing
to happen after one week after one month
or they want Clarity all at once do you
think that's the wrong approach yeah I
think if you're going to take a shot at
YouTube there's a couple of things you
have to think about you know one is is
the goal the ad revenue is it money or
is it impact and for me it's always been
impact the money has been amazing and
frankly I had no idea would be what it
is already and it's growing you know
monthly yeah but impact was my thing
right I I came to this situation already
financially secure and YouTube's an
amazing place I could I touch people
every day thousands of people every day
I now get somewhere between 20 and 30
messages a day thanking me and it just
keeps you going I never want to stop
um I actually it's funny I did every day
for almost three years it got to the
point where I was like I need to I need
to back off so I start taking Fridays
and Saturdays off which I'm not always
good at yeah but I do take them off
occasionally but yeah it's about I give
it three hours a day five days a week
yeah so it's it just feels good it
really does that's powerful and what you
just shared there three hours a day five
days a week is what sustains all of the
content that you're creating and so
you've uploaded 10 000 videos yes it's a
really shocking number and it's cool to
be having you on the think media podcast
at this moment because that's a
significant Milestone you recently hit
it yes YouTube Just rounds it at this
point so I mean I got it I got a note uh
I think it was six weeks ago it might
have been seven weeks ago that my 10 000
video was loaded yeah it's pretty wild
and so what is the system because for
someone listening they heard the
headline of the opening no editing but
what is basically now your system and
workflow for publishing content yeah so
it's really easy so really I do two
things on one rental at a time you've
already brought up the daily Financial
show that is Mike Zuber right Mike
zuber's commitment to delivering that
but really what makes one rental and
what's that show Daily financial news so
what's the framework of it so so for I
hit the record I hit the go live button
they're all live unless I'm traveling in
the world and internet is bad I go live
at 7 30 a.m on the dot worst case I'm a
minute late which very rarely happens
but it's it's that schedule so you can
count on me being live at 7 30 Pacific
Sunday through Thursday it goes for 12
to 18 minutes based on the topics and
I'm done yeah that's it and to be even a
little bit more detailed sure now you
have like a little studio and a
whiteboard correct and you've got a
couple things going on so it's turned
into a show Absolutely and again right
this is the evolution right in the
beginning it was me just talking to my
phone then it was my computer and then
thanks to think media and what you've
shared I got a camera that you
recommended so thank you it's amazing
but yeah it's just grown up I took ad
revenue and invested back in the
business right I didn't I had the money
to go buy the toys but that wasn't it it
wasn't about the toys it was it was
about getting better at my craft and it
just takes repetition so now it went
from my kids bedroom
um to a studio that's about a mile down
the road and it actually has three
different rooms in it right I carved it
up so my daily financial news is in the
middle it's all sound proof there's a
whiteboard and it's five topics and
again that's because of you right I used
to come in I used to say good morning
good afternoon good evening it's just I
would waste time the hook right to use
your language so again you always have
to be be finding other mentors and help
getting better at your craft now it's
five things occasionally there's a sixth
thing that's kind of some random thing
but it's pretty much the same format
every day so the pillar then and you
mentioned that's kind of your personal
brand it's your show you've decided to
be seven days a week
um and that's like the consistent
foundation and for those listening
you mentioned if you can't go live or if
you're on the road you recently took
like a very Dynamic international travel
tour on a cruise with incredibly slow
Wi-Fi but you stayed consistent how did
you do that so I would record uh the
evening before and Wi-Fi on on a ship is
not great so you have I loaded it at the
evening I was able to get it live at 7
30 every day except one which I think it
went at 9 30 that one day just because
it was so slow uh but no it's important
for me at least not to miss and if I was
going to miss I would tell the audience
why right the community tab or something
exactly there'd be no surprise and you
were just using your smartphone and you
plug in some kind of microphone I did
yes yeah do you know what my Q phone you
use I don't I can it's like a little is
it Wireless no that one has a wire on it
I tried a wireless one I didn't like it
got it so it's just a little lightning
Port microphone correct and and you were
able to keep the show going obviously
without the Whiteboard correct but you
made a promise and I think that you know
before we go into the other half of the
show what is the importance in your
opinion that you've experienced in terms
of Just The Compound Effect of being
consistent and making a promise and
actually showing up and fulfilling on
your word well it's just it's just you
it's so rare today right there's a lot
of people going after different messages
but they're not consistent and also one
thing that you'll see on my channel why
I have 10 000 videos so I don't believe
anything right and I make a lot of calls
and some of them are wonderful and some
of them are horrible so I like it that
people can hold me accountable and go
back and watch them I just did a whole
run of you know revisiting some of the
earlier videos that don't have a lot of
views so
um people can go back and watch and I I
have receipts so yeah that's a lot of
fun that's cool okay so so that's seven
days a week right there that's seven
uploads in a seven day period so then
what's the other part of how you reach
10 000 uploads so I think the key at
least it's my opinion what makes one
rental at a time unique is it's not Mike
Zuber other than the daily financial
news which I feel is my baby maybe now
it's my you know a child it's past the
baby phase I have uh eight to ten
different returning guests a week and we
spend 50 to 60 minutes and we type three
topics and then those get scheduled out
over the rest of the time so again one
rental at a time is a collection of
millionaires who got there with real
estate and that's very unique it's it's
not Mike Zuber right yeah I'm building a
website now that really highlights the
Millionaires and people who are part of
the community because it is all of us
it's different stories real estate you
can do lots of different things houses
commercial other things so I want to
provide a platform as long as you we
click and we're not scammy and no down
and leverage this and all that bring
them into the family and and you know
help a lot of people so people can
visualize this and I've been a guest a
few times the reason it's no editing is
you bring a guest on zoom
and you
figure out the three topics right within
the first 60 seconds yeah it's it's a
minute or two so you're like what do you
think about this and so this is me on
the show you're like I was thinking we
talk about this and then you're like
thumbs up or thumbs down I'm like yeah
that's that sounds good and I and even
for me I start like jotting like a note
or two or maybe a framework I have off
to the side I was thinking about we'd
hit this we did this and maybe we'll hit
this if we have the time exactly and
then you're like here we go and you
press record on Zoom I do which from my
perspective with no critique whatsoever
but even that I would much rather use
stream yard okay for example not so
exactly I'm not suggesting you change
I'm inspired that you even don't because
simply from the fact of it just proves I
mean again 80k a month growing multiple
six figures from other income streams
we'll touch on that but you've got the
book you've got all the other stuff but
like creativity works best in
constraints like Simplicity is power so
it's literally just zoom which I'm
trying to suffocate the excuses of
everybody listening to this because
everybody's using them a hundred percent
of people not everyone's used other
things but like do because we all went
through the pandemic 100 of people been
on Zoom to me Zoom is amazing and I
don't know stream yard I've never used
it exactly so I might actually suggest
you change I'm just saying that like
from my vantage point I'm like I'm
personally offended actually that that
you but also excited on the side because
it just proves that really it's not the
production value and and especially in
this Niche which is educational it
really is the content value there's
people are not critiquing that they're
there for the conversations the topics
you bring out the millionaire guests so
you get the guest on Zoom
you literally just press record have the
conversation and turn it off correct
that is the upload this is the whole
process we get on for 60 seconds three
topics yeah one two three there are 12
to 15 minutes yeah I hit start stop each
time so there's three different files
yes and then those download on my
computer and then I upload them to
YouTube and then they can be schedule
uploaded and I schedule upload yes who
does the titles and thumbnails I do the
titles I now pay someone to do the
thumbnails because I'm I got graphics
where'd you find them uh in my network
in Fresno so it's like a local domestic
person yeah actually they're now in
Mexico but they were local so how do you
once they're uploaded do you say Hey you
know I'm very consistent so they know
they're all uploaded by so they just do
them on autopilot correct so so the
system is created that the files are
there
and they they know to pull the guests or
they know because they've been working
with you for a while too because a lot
of times it's a picture of like you and
the guest with some other kind of
graphic or whatever and then they have
somewhat like of a template for daily
financial news so so the thumbnails are
rocking you do the titles correct and
vid IQ helps me makes suggestions oh
yeah vid IQ AI title generator correct
yeah pretty pretty at least again it's
very easy for me right I put in what I
think and then it cleans it up I use it
90 of the time sometimes it just doesn't
feel right and then shorts did I know we
talked did you decide to just put them
all on the same channel so I have two
shorts going on my main Channel and I'm
trying to grow a shorts only Channel
how's that going oh it's slow but why
not why not who does the shorts same guy
the guy that does the thumbnails as the
shorts okay so your and then that's the
whole thing that's thumbnails titles vid
IQ helping with optimization and
millionaire interview conversations
those are daily financial news everybody
knows their time
and reverse engineer that over enough
time 10 000 uploads and now in the last
year and I think we talked about this
how much did you generate an ad Revenue
over 80 000 just from AdSense how many
subscribers right now almost fifty
thousand forty seven thousand I think
and if you become a one rental at a time
follower which you're throwing a party
yeah fifty thousand I won't plan a
minute of it until we hit fifty thousand
I don't like cashing checks early yeah
50 000 we're doing an event in Vegas
that's that's cool I am fully committed
to being there I'm excited for it okay
so um that's all pumping out and then
what are the other income streams so I
wrote a book one rental at a time yes uh
it's still a couple thousand dollars a
month and that was published I think 18.
power of a self-published book is it an
audio too it is now and it's on Audible
okay so you have the audio ebook and
physical book correct and when it's
self-published you make good margins
seven bucks a book on Amazon yeah okay
and we'll by the way link everything up
in the show notes and and that would be
that's not going to really help you with
content creation but that's going to
help you take your it's the the idea is
consistency yeah right one rental at a
time but it's going to teach you how to
invest in real estate sure practically
that's also one of the things I love
about you because a lot of people out
here just talking about multi-family
stuff and all kinds of stuff which is
all you know whatever syndications right
now are all getting squeezed you what I
what I love about you is it's the
anybody can do it you're very
conservative yes and wise
and some people prescribe
things that are a little sketchy that
could put people that make them very
vulnerable yeah there's a lot of things
in real estate because there's a lot of
money and leverage and all these things
I've I've been doing it 20 some odd
years and seen people blow up right and
I don't want that for anyone I I really
push the idea if you just get to four
doors four doors it could be four four
plexors four houses four whatever yeah
uh your your financial future is bright
yeah you don't need 40. you don't need
400 or something and you can do it with
a practical salary at your job setting
some money aside being thoughtful and
and so of course there's videos on your
Channel about it but there's the book so
we're talking about income streams so
you have ad revenue and and that was as
you said three hours a day to do it all
yep to do the news do you count your
research time no I would do that anyway
because you do that anyway that's a joy
for you so you do that anyway the time
to do shoot for daily financial news
schedule with your guests film with your
guests title schedule upload communicate
if you need to with your thumbnail
shorts person and then you check out
yeah done what do you do the rest of the
day the rest of the day they go home
while Olivia and I will go have lunch
that's our thing we're Foodies yeah go
someplace eat lunch then I will exercise
in the kind of early afternoon yeah and
then you know if a warrior game's on
I'll watch that if not we'll go do
something and you're also still actively
I mean you you talk about the deals that
you do so how much time do you devote to
I'm probably spending an hour a day
probably looking at deals which really
is the same hour I spent the last time
that's what you teach it's what I teach
yeah it's your buy box buy box that's
right 20 minutes a day okay so uh to
I've rabbit trailed our way away so
we're talking about ad Revenue the book
what else is hard so there's courses
again which I never thought I would
create one but it's been wildly
successful I just who I am how to get
started one Roots a lot at a time seven
steps unteachable yeah again why
teachable because it was easy for me
again it's it's video quality not
produced not edited none of that's even
edited it's just who I am yeah and that
was several hundred thousand dollars a
year yeah and then and then you like
recently threw an event you put that up
and actually you give that away as part
of your course yeah it's in the course
it's in the bonus sections yeah but also
now it's a it's a feeder right because I
was seeing this just one course now I do
events with 100 people on Zoom again I
can save those files and give them out
as for 40 bucks or whatever it is so
there's more content coming in other
areas where people can like I'm gonna
you know I'm not ready to spend 400 but
I wanna I wanna try this right I did a
deep dive on buy box for example yeah
and so have you figured out that then
um are you uploading all these to the
Corsair and whatnot are you also
Outsourcing some help in regards no I do
that I upload those yeah so what I'm
hoping that comes across here is again
you figured out first you retired got
bored really quick yes wanted to make an
impact wanted to make a difference thing
one which is so resin resonates with our
ethos at think media
um and you need money for the mission so
we're all we're not apologetic about
pursuing the revenue but it but people
that listen to this want to make a
difference they want to make an impact
to people you're doing that you're
getting all these messages but it's also
your model is is different and it's
sustainable it's definitely not the only
way other content niches
I would argue demand editing probably
this one doesn't because it's so heavy
education whereas you know some of these
Cinema if you were teaching
cinematography and editing right you
know like because like if you were these
if you're kind of a Casey neistat
vlogger well that's that is the story
time and it's all this but in terms of
this these a lot of niches and even
listeners to this I think could really
uh benefit and it's practical and then
you've built it over years you have a
sustainable system a nice Rhythm and
then you also have you do all the back
end yep you wrote the book yes you you
built out the course you you can you can
do all the things over time and I hope
that that's an encouragement to the
listeners I'm curious for someone saying
well easy for you to say you built all
these connections what is your advice
for actually building if someone's like
man I want to start tapping into a
strong network of people to have guests
on the show and all of how you've done
that of all my guests I only knew one of
them
previous
you just you just reach out to people
cold okay right I reached out to you
Colt yes right and said hey can we try
this once and I again I've reached out
to some people and they've we've done
one show and we will never do another
one because I got that
Vibe is like doesn't click with one
rental at a time yeah but the ones that
click and they come back I asked them
right and Anna Kelly was the first one
to do it right it's a very different
story right REI mom she sold a big house
in Texas house Act of fourplex in
Pennsylvania she lived upstairs just
just amazing stories just being a good
person and networking in your area it
can come again you could do I really
think one rental at a time in what I
call the millionaires could work in any
area find like if you like classic cars
find other classic cars folks and just
talk and if people love to hear
competing views and we don't always
agree totally right and that's okay we
respect each other we'll listen and
we'll also call each other out when
we're wrong there's just something in
that of having two knowledgeable people
who are go-givers
riffing on a topic it doesn't have to be
confrontational it doesn't have to be
sensationalized people really really
appreciate that I think yeah that's
super powerful um so in just a second I
want to get into some questions even
about how people can prepare for what
may be coming even this year uh get some
of your perspective on how we can uh be
more intelligent financially as content
creators and as entrepreneurs I want to
encourage those listeners uh if you want
to check out any of Michael's resources
especially if you want to start earning
extra money or exploring that with real
estate the book is a no-brainer the
YouTube channel is a no-brainer but you
can also check out his course and all
that stuff in the description as well
but before we transition into a few
other questions what advice do you have
for somebody that is in a similar season
of life as you the content creator that
it or as you were and as you are now
years into it with with momentum and
success and the network and the Rhythm
and a level of I would say the
confidence the confidence is built
because now it's here it's and it's all
hindsight now but the person who's
looking at starting this yeah what are
people going to think what do I have
unique to say to the camera conversation
you know is it too late to start you
know should I start
a YouTube show or a video podcast or
something like that what advice would
you have I would tell someone you know
going back at 45 I probably should have
started earlier but it's absolutely
worth it I actually think what you were
gonna see and I I can see it because I'm
in it every day already transitioning I
think you can grow fast on YouTube being
negative in clickbaity and all of that I
think that's going to have its time as
AI sort of works a way to weed out that
people really are drawn to value and
impact so again if you're 45 years old
and you have a hobby or a passion that
you've spent time with there is a show
there and oh by the way if it happens to
be something you already love it won't
feel like work I spent three hours a day
on this and I'm excited for all of it
yeah it is just so much fun so uh I
would tell you to just press play and go
and I would tell you to stop
overthinking it yeah it's literally it's
daily financial news what I do is I take
notes usually I have a page of notes and
I just tie it all together yeah and then
my millionaires you're absolutely right
we get on the phone nothing's been
prepped I'm like here's a couple of Hot
Topics in in the news and I ask I always
ask do you have a topic and we just go
for 12 to 15 minutes it's it's a
conversation it doesn't have to be and
if it's something you love and you truly
try to help go find two or three other
people go look in the Facebook groups go
to others there's got to be other use
out there yeah so be the Hub
and just bring on other amazing people
it's powerful advice and you know I also
want to just address the objection where
you know someone might be saying Sean
are you saying we shouldn't edit well
that's not what I'm prescribing at all I
think you need to find out your Rhythm
and your style and while one rental at a
time is not everybody's cup of tea of
course you're also not the only you know
game in town only show in town but I
think it proves how much diversity and
opportunity there is there's a lot of
different real estate voices a lot of
different at different levels but when
people hear the numbers and the growth I
like to encourage people too you're
gonna get that silver play button but
you're not even halfway at this exact
moment and already crushing multiple six
figures and a lot of times we'll talk
about that at think media where
um the the unknown creators the
non-famous creators which become micro
celebrities in your community like
because people who know you they hang
out they spend 365 days a year with you
yes there's people who like spend more
time with you than Buy like most of
their family members in a way yeah more
consistent for sure but but like it's
just so powerful to start and to then
find a workflow that works for you
that's what I want people to be
thoughtful like the workflow works for
you it's sustainable for you it's the
way you want to do it yeah and it really
resonates with your followers I am one I
can also pick and choose daily
financials my staple if I see any of the
other topics that interest me I can
click on those you know and so very
powerful very inspiring
um Switching gears a little bit
recession odds are at 70 percent and the
US faces stag a stagflation problem one
report says and of course uh but it
could be could be true how should people
prepare for a recession context here you
definitely have business owners you have
content creators aspiring content
creators your background in education is
as an economist correct and you're
studying finances all the time what are
your predictions
and how do you suggest we prepare so
first couple thoughts the chances of a
recession are 100 percent
they are actually natural part of the
business cycle yeah and I'll even go
this far I hope you live through five of
them right that just means you lived a
full life they're that normal yes so the
chances of a recession are 100 now the
argument is when that's Up For Debate
I've actually on record saying I think
it starts Q2 which is the you know the
month that we're recording right it
starts in April okay we won't know that
for nine months I think the odds that it
starts sometime this year are very high
probably in the 90s there is a chance we
have a soft Landing which I'll Define as
less than Trend growth call it sub one
percent but not negative but inflation
is high and that's the dreaded
stagflation that is the 70s right it's
just right icky but as an entrepreneur
which I think really makes this economy
go right the small business owner know
that recessions are when you make moves
and it's not doesn't have to be money
but there will be so many people out
there nervous or cutting back or doing
things you can buy toys cheap right
whether that's a fancy camera or a per
or whatever your thing is there will be
playing I need people trying to raise
Capital because they need cash to pay
the bills because they were stimulus
Ballers when you know everybody's
getting money but recessions are when
you make moves it was ridiculously easy
in my business of real estate to make
money for two years like 2020 and 2021
all the frauds came out anybody could do
it right sign a contract sell the
contract make you a bunch of money
that's over they're already going away
but if you focus on being a good
operator whatever your thing is there
will be less of you every quarter for
the next eight quarters and you will
come out of this thing just a monster
this is my third real big recession that
meaning the.com and the Great Recession
I don't count the covered recession even
though that was there was one there it
was such a v-shaped recovery not normal
but yeah recession typically is 18
months on average
uh but then the good times are about
eight to ten years so we are in the bad
time
you can argue when it starts but it's
it's around the corner and so you're
saying one of the ways to prepare and
flourish during a recession is to be a
good operator what are a few of the
distinctions that make a good operator
whatever your thing is it's no longer
gambling when when it's a hockey stick
you take you take chances with money oh
I've never done direct mail again I'm
speaking to my business I'm gonna give
it a shot it's only a grand who cares
well that's not going to fly in and
you're not going to take that shot
you're going to keep that money in dry
powder and and do something else with it
it's smart moves it's moves that you
know there's a return on it's not hiding
it's being more focused in in doing that
in entrepreneurship some people say you
got to play offense some people say you
can't you know a good defense wins games
which are you offense or defense well
I've again I believe in a recession you
have to prepare for it so if you follow
my channel you know that I told people
six months ago time to get ready what
does that mean to me that means take all
my debt that we was variable and get it
fixed right I had apartment buildings uh
fixed to 3.99 now people are losing
Apartments because rates are in the
seventh right so you you when you see
them coming you can make moves to
prepare yeah but now I've done that I've
cleaned up my balance sheet I've cleaned
up my income statement now it's like
let's go find some deals because
there'll be less people with cash they
can write checks there'll be less people
that are creative and oh by the way I'm
in Vegas because I needed to skill up
I've identified two areas in my business
where I don't have depth of experience
one is large apartment buildings I don't
know that we'll do one but I'm willing
to listen and learn and go get around
that room be the small fish in a
different room and the other one is
creative financing I've done seller
financing but not sub 2 and other things
so I will investigate other areas that
are like tools missing on my tool belt
in this time so again invest in yourself
find out what you may need and
go after it what advice would you give
to the non-real estate investor to
prepare for recession so the first thing
I would do is look at look at your past
90 days of spending right this is this
the good news about this you only do
this once where did my money go the big
thing for me is what's a need versus a
want we're not doing any wants right now
we're only doing needs yeah okay that's
the big thing and it's uncomfortable and
if you have the fortitude to do it I
would I would share with somebody the
the results of that because what you may
think is a need
so process it with others that you to
get some really unbiased feedback or
somebody that will speak some truth and
love to you yes because any cash that
you can save now on a monthly basis will
be dry powder for those things because
there will be amazing opportunities to
make moves but you've got to get ready
for that there was an article that
unmashable that asked the question is
the creator economy really Recession
Proof what do you think about when you
think about content creators video
podcasters entrepreneurs creating
content do you think it's Recession
Proof I think if you're a good operator
it absolutely is recession-proof what I
do and what we've talked about earlier
schedule process plan keep going people
can rely on it you don't get sketchy you
don't you know you don't change
mid-flight and do something else and
drop this and drop that absolutely but
that said there will be a lot of people
in the game that aren't in the game in
the year because they're not consistent
they're they're not focused in my
opinion and so part of one of the things
I'm hearing you say just to clarify a
good operator has a lot to do with good
Finance actual stewardship yeah you
because when you don't have that that
pressure is real yeah it makes you it
can make you make poor decisions just to
alleviate pain so you must prepare I
strongly suggest prepare for it yeah so
you can make moves with confidence and
keeping I mean what is one of your
quotes that you say you say get to get
close to revenue yes get close to
revenue absolutely what does that mean
so one of the things that that um in a
good economy all right like that was
taking off there's all these special
projects and yeah you've heard all the
tech companies we hired a bunch of
people it was an arms race they didn't
know what they would do but they were
talented so we hired them they're now
being let go yeah right so what I
strongly suggest is the closer that you
can get in its core Revenue the more
likely you are not what's core Revenue
so again like let's talk about whether
it be Google or you know any of these
companies they have these special
projects like that's the future of the
company then your your accountant going
into a recession going I need to whack
eight percent what's that group over
there there's no Revenue but wow look at
that head count
you're seeing a lot of that happen and
let's be clear that's not in in the
Silicon Valley what I shared a year ago
was not popular I had a bunch of
Engineers and computer scientists
telling me you're crazy I'm the future
of the company I know we don't sell
anything but you just wait now they're
coming back to me going you were right I
got laid off
and so for so for the non-tech worker or
non-ceo of a company
get get close to revenue would mean cut
unnecessary expenses yeah don't take
flyers now this is not the time to try
something left field yeah right what I
would tell you to do whether you're a
content creator is stay core right for
me everything's one rental at a time I'm
not going to become a gold show yeah or
something else and yeah we say find the
shortest path to revenue it's like find
the simplest business plan find
something solid work it keep expenses
low don't spend your money on dumb stuff
spend your money on content creation for
what it costs which could mean I always
encourage people too that could mean a
plane ticket it could be it could it
like something it could mean to
collaborate you don't need my gear
doesn't have to be that expensive but
those types of Investments sometimes we
can become techaholics a little bit or
buying unnecessary stuff but if but you
want the essentials if it supports your
core business what you're saying cut the
felonious expenditures and stay on the
things that actually move the needle and
get close to revenue Watcher p l yeah
watch the piano again know what brings
you know whatever that is for you you
know dollars in the door do more of that
get better at that there will be a time
to expand there will be a tie to try new
things it's not in a recession at the
time of recording this May 1st we
there's a bunch of people are announcing
their presidential runs Biden announced
that he's running Trump has announced
that he's running how much do you think
this timing with an election here in the
U.S
in 2024 is going to affect the economy
well it always does I mean if you go
back and study history president the
year before presidential election I mean
I certainly if you look at the stock
market charts they're always usually up
and to the right meaning later in the
year they get better it's going to be
the topic it will be the economy in my
opinion the election will come down to
the economy do you think that uh the
current state of the economy is truly
the current presidential uh Joe Biden
and the Democratic party's fault or do
you think they inherited a lot of it uh
I think both parties sort of got into it
this started right the the the kindling
that became what we are suffering now
was started before that yeah right a lot
of this came down because we chose to
shut the economy down it shows you you
choose once you chose that yeah
it was a domino effect and then printed
zillions of dollars or whatever the heck
the number is we're going to be sucking
that out I mean M2 money supply which
you know is this fancy thing about how
is being it's gone negative since first
time since 1933. and if you want to go
ahead and see what happened in 1933 it's
called the Great Depression yeah right
we've just done that wow so pretty crazy
stuff going on so do you think uh you
know hot takes on the podcast that that
really the Democratic party has a chance
because at the end of the day when you
count voting a lot of times it comes
down to economy there is a lot of issues
and there's a lot of hot button issues
but when people are experiencing pain
financially right and I don't want to
blame somebody they want to blame
somebody
and so do you think it it flips in this
election well again I think so let me
let me play this out so it's 2023 May
1st I believe we're going to be in a
recession let's call it for 12 months
yeah
he might get lucky
because people are going to remember the
last six months so you mean it might
start kind of turning around right you
may if there's an upswing right right
before which is hard to it's hard to
time right you're not gonna remember
last year when you were unemployed
you're gonna be happy oh I got a job now
yeah so it's not so much the bad economy
which I think gets worse for the rest of
the year but there is a chance that this
looks better next summer in the
elections in November he might get lucky
I'm not calling that I think this might
be two years but I could tell you it
might 12 months right so you might get
lucky on timing but yeah it'll be about
the economy I think so as we land the
plane what are some of just your final
as an operator yourself a lot of our
community one can learn from you because
you've been there you've done that
you've had a lot of lessons a lot of
others this conversation is actually
stepping outside of what we normally
would talk about and some people are
like dude I'm just trying to start a
YouTube channel like I'm just trying to
get a side income going I'm trying to
you know get out of my day job I'm
trying to I'm trying to go part-time I'm
trying to quit I'm trying to figure this
thing out what what are maybe some of
the habits or the traits that you think
are essential disciplines routines for
someone to you know eventually be able
to quit their day job and ultimately
lean into their dream job which for 99
of our listeners is to is to create what
you have done and that is a a YouTube
channel a media company a solo ran yeah
with a few people helping YouTube
channel that pays the bills and that
gives freedom and allows to give you a
platform and a voice what are some of
the habits disciplines things people
should study Lifestyle the way people
should be you know yeah if they're
wanting to get into this I think most
people
over complicated right if you're coming
to this you're coming to think media you
have something you're passionate about
it could have been a lifetime hobby I
mean it could be anything Star Wars it
could be whatever that is yeah all in my
model find your thing around that make
that your show for me that's the daily
financial news and then go find four or
five other amazing folks who are willing
to give you one hour a week but don't
want to have their own channel but they
like giving they like discussing
it builds itself
right you have to be consistent I would
tell if you're going to start you can't
do less than 100 videos right I think
too many people before judging it yeah
before you're not gonna find out your
Rhythm your talk and nobody watches the
first hundred anyway so it's like the
first Pancake it doesn't really look
like anything yeah right so just just
just go for it yeah I love it well
Michael Zuber really appreciates you for
those people that want to connect with
you follow you uh where you at of course
we'll link everything up in the show
Notes One rental at a time everywhere